black hole don't think so picture of
black hole more like
[Music]
since its sands that's right you know
from now on at least I don't think it
always used to be this but now anytime
there's a leap in humanity people are
just gonna mean this even the lady that
did the code for the black hole thing of
course you post a picture of yourself in
front of a screen that's like asking to
get a Minecraft edit right on top of
that you just been trolololo lord
lambeth esta no DreamWorks its Shrek
she's watching Shrek and it's not even
blurry a black hole you might say
Ricardo why don't they just focus the
lens I don't understand why it's blurry
probably because a woman did the photo
that's a blatant sexist lie let's watch
some means where people ruin the black
hole oh look it's that one right
oh look it's that that's pretty good
I'm never gonna be able to see these
creepy eyes the same way now thanks
thanks black hole you ruined it
profile pic versus tag pic side there
you go scientists take a picture of
black hole weaves this brings whole new
meaning to animate thoughts thank you
matter say ah ah if Steven Hawkins lived
one more year he could have seen the
black
oh this is so sad that's actually saying
black hole I don't give up vegetable
light you literally can't take photos of
me some intelligent thing on a rock does
it anyway black hole yes what is it oh
Jesus that's creepy
it's the I am sour on everyone that's my
Mario and Bowser impression everyone in
case anyone wondered what that sounds
like
magnify that black hole why is it failed
blurry that's the resolution we have
making it bigger doesn't make it clearer
but why don't they just focus on it the
photo of the black hole is blurry but if
you zoom and enhance then you can see
it's called destructive power my god
Xbox Xbox was blackhole all along it's a
magic incredible with a Ricardo she's a
lucky gal NASA captures first image of
black hole ready yeah there you go
pretty much flew to then flew to now
black hole damn black hole now your
girlfriend then your girl for now you
don't have a girlfriend
pathetic video over tuber simulator it's
now so relevant
just kidding still here black hole memes
gets a 5 good job by black hole we have
a lot of means to go through today I
don't think I ever had this many
different means incredible let's just
get through it because yep first of all
I don't find it anything funny about a
historical monument burning down ok my
first reaction was shocked and I'm
deeply sad about this beautiful
architecture getting destroyed no that's
out of the way it's not like anyone died
but still you can still be sad about
something and still laugh about it
that's fine in my opinion so why don't
we just go through the meal not your
damn own fire it's the most
aesthetically pleasing visually I've
ever seen I'm going to burn your mother
we'll see if it's that
well people clearly are very opinionated
about this thing looks like you missed
your French lesson again idea to that
trip to Paris then HD news
Paris cat they draw devastated duolingo
strikes again good lord what's happening
hints today that's the first time I ever
laughed at a steamed hams meme good job
basically right at everyone you did it
this is that's right why is no one
talking about Quasimodo what is oh that
is a static come on choose me on that
fire well we know who did it
nobody friends people please you don't
understand French people I already have
enough enemies okay I'm not trying to
make me once I'm just trying to enjoy
memes the sacred - damn it oh my god did
this happen alright we now know the
perpetrator Quasimodo he's ugly that's
how you know he did it
lie down try not to cry cry a lot this
is so sad
I mean when the I don't know what the
thing in the back is called but then
when that Bell is like it is shocking I
get it and Quasimodo is of course now
going to mean heaven sayonara Quasimodo
Sam we also now know the perpetrator
ninja it was ninja Nina did what
nunna ninja how could you do this ten
minute video of course he exploits the
ad revenue on a tragedy putting it in
the thumbnail discussing I would never
do such not your damn burning me just
poor Holy Mother
damn it Catholic promise require
Catholic solutions French Revolution
World War One World War two construction
work how did this happen I don't
understand sir you've been in a coma for
850 years
oh boy can't wait to isn't my favorite
intact French Cathedral
when you're devastated by fire but
nobody is saying a sad baguette noise
can we get some EPS in the chance please
I don't respect integrity that this
channel upholds and that's it
next meme running officer Earl memes
yeah there it is run no one runs light
officer Earl no way Jesus Christ you
know eventually they'll just be a meme
for any body movement or any form of
expression you won't have you don't need
to have your own feelings and thoughts
anymore just associated to me to a meme
now running has finally been
appropriated to this I don't know if
that's the right way to put it to steam
if that his name I don't remember Oh
officer Earl officer Earl is now the
official meme of running congratulations
everyone we've done it there's also a
couple captions me throw sticks good boy
and words can you stop using the word
end please Felix came back home from
Japan Edgar me my little bro racing to
get front seat
it's kind of cute turns off like
downstairs me running up the stairs to
escape the demons cool any time I do
anything running now just think of
officer Earl nobody if I don't reach
that tree before that car I'll start
computer disk or Spotify inseam okay all
right we get it
oh my god it's Shawnie
quite an that tooth TSA so nickel
okay I think we get it he's running fast
officer Earl run fast run a face officer
Earl this mean gets to by next meal we
have that OSH here we go again here we
go again
from GTA san andreas one of the greatest
games of all time someone made a green
screen template of it and of course that
opens up for vigilia new memes but
reduce it here we go again here we go
again maybe going hey it fries too here
we go again we go again okay
[Music]
when you finally defeat the main villain
but there's a second part when you die
but then you remember you're a Buddhist
ah the plot or every Mario game ah here
we go again
PewDiePie getting another sponsorship
from pub G mobile balázs here we go
again
great me I don't see lasting very long I
think probably I finally watched Jojo so
now I can finally understand with more
death
the Jojo memes and now there's the oh
you're approaching me meme becoming very
popular
oh you're approaching me on your own
volition
oh no coup de luca nickelodeon it's
cosmetic oh no car sick cookies egg
spoilers when you go blaze rod farming
in Minecraft there's basically this this
screen from the manga where deer walks
and the most absolute savage way
possible
that's right walking is now a meme
everyone it's green finally so bad but
so good coca-cola versus Pepsi well I
guess we know coca-cola wins dog is
messing with something in the other room
I would be right bank Hey such a bad man
but it's so good oh you're approaching
me I can't eat you without getting
closer oh my God Jesus Christ is this
from the same part the manga and the
anime it doesn't seem like it I don't
know guys I got I gotta go sleep good
name
goddammit when you're facing the final
boss with a customizable character in
the cutscene god yeah oh you can have
that as a oh dude I want that wait where
did mom go
if a guy just snotted everywhere yeah I
am here this is so wholesome and sweet
the teacher isn't here
we're legally allowed to leave 15
minutes have passed
sayonara sensei son chad versus virgin
who's ever well maybe that's it that's
all the time we have for me review great
memes this week really good stuff just
as long as you stop using copyrighted
things as memes that would be great
thank you very much hope you guys
enjoyed this episode if you did check
out merch limited time only the name or
view out goodbye everyone to burst
simulator it's now so relevant that it's
got a brand new minigame crania drop the
crane and get fresh items only available
in the washing machine like game and you
say there's more of course there is new
knowledge perks new quests and new pics
links and legs guys lake
[Music]